y
[Música]
y rusia e intercambian prisioneros la
vice primera ministra ucraniana afirma
que 14 personas regresarán a su país
pero no dijo cuántos rusos serán
devueltos otra parte medios de moscú
hablan de evacuaciones en mariupol y los
militares rusos avanzan en el este
escala la violencia en cisjordania los
hombres armados le dispararon a un
guardia de seguridad israelí y horas
después el ejército de israel arremetió
contra un palestino de 27 años en las
últimas semanas al menos 15 personas han
muerto
y hoy tres provincias de ecuador
entrarán en estado de excepción por la
creciente violencia del narcotráfico el
presidente guillermo lasso decretó la
medida para las regiones costeras de
guayas manabí y esmeraldas la emergencia
regirá durante 60 días e incluye toques
de queda nocturnos en algunas ciudades
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
soy maría clara calle y es un gusto
saludarlos y comenzamos en ucrania
porque la viceprimera ministra irina
bereziuk afirmó que intercambiarán a
siete soldados y a siete civiles
ucranianos pero no precisó cuántos rusos
serán devueltos
este gesto ocurre de manera paralela a
las acciones militares los rusos
bombardearon hoy jarquín la segunda
ciudad más importante de ucrania según
los militares de ese país al menos una
persona murió y otras cinco quedaron
heridas por su parte moscú afirmó que
sus unidades de artillería atacaron
389 objetivos ucranianos durante la
noche veamos
edificios residenciales en ruinas aquí
en la segunda ciudad ucraniana jarquín
[Aplausos]
un tanque pueda llegar a corta distancia
y disparar toda su munición sobre zonas
residenciales no le importa dónde y es
imposible saber dónde va a disparar
aquí no hay nada más servicios
especiales escuelas activarlo youtube
quincho conmemora el presidente
volodymyr se lens que dice que las
fuerzas ucranianas están haciendo
algunos avances en la región georges del
arsenal hackers la situación es difícil
en la región de jarquín pero nuestros
militares nuestra inteligencia tienen
importantes éxitos tácticos la última
estrategia de asalto de moscú lanzada el
18 de abril y concentrada en el sureste
del país va con retraso avanzando más
lentamente de lo previsto las fuerzas
rusas bombardearon el sábado en la
región oriental del donbass pero no
lograron capturar tres zonas objetivos
según los militares ucranianos mientras
tanto en la asediada ciudad portuaria de
mariupol continúan los bombardeos
concentrados en torno a la planta
siderúrgica de asof tal el último
bastión de la resistencia ucraniana
varios centenares de civiles soldados
siguen escondidos bajo tierra la onu ha
estado trabajando para negociar una
evacuación el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de rusia pareció descartar la
necesidad de su participación
no es necesario que nadie preste ayuda
para abrir corredores humanitarios sólo
hay un problema los corredores
humanitarios que se anuncian a diario
son ignorados por los ultra nacionales
ucranianos
el alcalde de mariupol ha vuelto a pedir
la evacuación de los civiles dijo que la
planta se está quedando sin alimentos
agua y medicinas
ucrania sostiene que la estrategia
militar de rusia es controlar la región
del donbass en el este a la vez que
aumenta su fuerza en las vecinas
ciudades de jarquín y mariupol en esta
última las discusiones se concentran en
la evacuación de los 2000 militares y
los 1000 civiles que resisten en la
planta de acero de as asustar al menos
600 de ellos estarían heridos según el
alcalde de mariupol quien pidió ayuda
internacional para evacuarlos por su
parte de los medios oficiales rusos tass
y ria sostienen que hoy 25 civiles
fueron evacuados de esta ciudad
portuaria escuchamos al portavoz del
ministerio de defensa ucraniano hablando
de la situación en el país
las tropas rusas están aumentando
gradualmente la intensidad de su
ofensiva en el este de ucrania
simultáneamente en todas las direcciones
y su mayor actividad se observa en el
globo yanqui donges además hay indicios
de que el agresor se está preparando una
activación aún mayor de acciones
militares el enemigo continúa con los
ataques aéreos en mariupol los
principales esfuerzos de los ocupantes
se concentran en bloquear nuestras
unidades cerca de la planta de azov tal
algunas tropas rusas también están
siendo re distribuidas en las
direcciones de pompas mind pavlik ski y
un nuevo pueblo esquina brinquen y
cambiamos de noticia un palestino y un
israelí murieron en las últimas horas
luego de enfrentamientos primero los
hombres armados le dispararon a un
guardia de seguridad en la entrada de
ariel uno de los mayores asentamientos
israelíes en la cisjordania ocupada
luego el ejército de israel arremetió
contra un palestino de 27 años en el
pueblo de azul este es el más reciente
hecho de una ola de violencia que se ha
intensificado en las últimas semanas del
ramadán y que se ha cobrado la vida de
15 personas veamos el informe
ariel y otros asentamientos cercanos
fueron cerrados a primera hora del
sábado después de que dos hombres
armados dispararan y mataron a un
guardia de seguridad y el escáner pgr un
vehículo con matrícula de amarillas
llegó al lugar dos terroristas estaban
dentro del coche y empezaron a disparar
cuyo robo las fuerzas de seguridad
israelíes han realizado detenciones y
han incautado armas en una localidad
cercana mientras el grupo militante
palestino vinculado a al fatah la
brigada de los mártires de al-aqsa
reivindicaba la autoría del atentado es
el último en un fuerte aumento de la
violencia entre israelíes y palestinos
en las últimas semanas en medio de un
aumento de las tensiones en torno al
complejo de la mezquita de al aqsa en
jerusalén este el tercer lugar más
sagrado del islám se encuentra en el
monte del templo el lugar más venerado
del judaísmo israel se anexionó
jerusalén del este junto con cisjordania
tras la guerra de los seis días de 1967
en una medida no reconocida por la
comunidad internacional además ha
impuesto restricciones que hacen
prácticamente imposible que la mayoría
de los palestinos
recen en la mezquita este mes se han
producido múltiples enfrentamientos en
el recinto al coincidir las
celebraciones musulmana del ramadán y la
pascua judía
queremos visitar la mezquita de al-aqsa
y rezar dentro porque hacerlo triplica
la recompensa
los ocupantes son responsables de la
agresión que está ocurriendo aquí
hace casi un año un desalojo de familias
palestinas de jerusalén éste provocó una
guerra de 11 días que terminó con un
acuerdo de alto el fuego entre israel y
hamás el grupo militante que gobierna
gaza los palestinos reclaman jerusalén
este como capital de su futuro estado
israel la llama su capital eterna desde
el diputado británico neil parís se
anunció su renuncia después de admitir
que vio pornografía dos veces estando en
el parlamento en una entrevista hoy con
la bbc parís dijo que la primera vez que
accedió a las imágenes porno fue de
manera accidental supuestamente mientras
visitaba un sitio web de tractores pero
acepto que la segunda vez si lo hizo de
manera deliberada el partido conservador
lo suspendió anoche y además el comité
de estándares de la cámara de los
comunes lo iba a investigar
y en francia a la izquierda intenta
unirse de cara a las elecciones
legislativas del 12 y 19 de junio el
partido de la francia y su misa le pidió
este sábado al partido socialista
acordar una coalición progresista
mientras que los ecologistas llegaron
hoy a la sede de aquel colectivo el
intento de unión llega después de que
los socialistas los verdes los
comunistas y la francia insumisa se
dividieran el voto de la izquierda en
las presidenciales con cuatro candidatos
diferentes de todos el aspirante de este
último partido jean luc mélenchon fue el
más votado por lo que su movimiento es
fundamental en una posible coalición
y los estragos del calentamiento global
continúan sintiéndose con intensidad en
india donde las temperaturas siguen
rodando los 44 grados celsius y son las
más altas que se han registrado en el
último siglo las autoridades
meteorológicas informaron que se espera
que la ola de calor se prolongue hasta
el 2 de mayo al tiempo el departamento
meteorológico de pakistán señaló que es
probable que las temperaturas diurnas
estén entre 5 y 8 grados por encima de
lo normal en grandes zonas de este país
y en noticias de eeuu el estado de
california en el oeste enfrenta una
sequía histórica que ya obligó a tres
condados a limitar el uso del agua el
racionamiento afectará a unas 6 millones
de personas y se aplicará a partir del
primero de junio y es que a pesar de que
el estado tiene múltiples fuentes
hídricas muchas de las reservas se están
secando rafael pérez nos habla de la
crisis
california es golpeada de lleno por una
sequía histórica la escasez de agua
obligó a las autoridades a imponer
restricciones este año los jardines no
lucirán su habitual verde con la
limitación de irrigar en exteriores sólo
un día por semana en el sur del estado
es necesario reaccionar ahora para
realmente tener agua disponible para
nosotros en interiores para que bebamos
y para nuestra seguridad así que esto es
una crisis esto no tiene precedentes y
debemos hacerlo ahora ese es un
presidente aunque las restricciones se
aplicarán a partir del primero de junio
en decenas de ciudades de los condados
de los ángeles ventura y san bernardino
en los que habitan unas 6 millones de
personas
california el estado más poblado de
estados unidos con cerca de 40 millones
de habitantes posee varias fuentes de
agua provenientes de lagos y ríos
también en las montañas y esas reservas
se están secando
no hay nieve que se derrita y ese es el
cambio del clima lo sabemos según
expertos el cambio climático es un
factor fundamental en esta crisis
el cambio climático ha alterado
fundamentalmente el ciclo de agua de
nuestro estado intensificando el clima
extremo y provocando periodos más largos
y secos las autoridades se recomiendan
bajar el consumo no imprescindible en un
35% para que los suministros sigan
siendo viables
cuál es el peor de los resultados si la
gente ignora las medidas no quiero
llegar ahí pero podemos llegar a un día
en el que abras el grifo y no salga agua
en internet a manos de la cámara o del
30 al 70 por ciento del agua que se
utiliza en los hogares o negocios se
emplea en exteriores por lo que las
medidas son más estrictas para la
jardinería y es que ya son tres años
consecutivos de una sequía severa por lo
que se plantea la posibilidad de aplicar
restricciones aún más drásticas a partir
de septiembre
desde hoy a medianoche comienza un
estado de excepción en tres provincias
de ecuador el presidente guillermo lasso
decretó la medida para las regiones
costeras de guayas manabí y esmeraldas
esta es la segunda vez que el mandatario
utiliza poderes de emergencia para
contrarrestar la violencia que está
disparada desde el año pasado y que está
vinculada con las bandas de narcotráfico
juan pabló lucumí nos cuenta los
detalles
el aumento de la violencia llevó al
presidente de ecuador a tomar la
decisión he declarado estado de
excepción en las provincias del guayas
manabí y esmeraldas efectivo desde la
medianoche de hoy una medida que se
extenderá por al menos 60 días ahí se
movilizarán cuatro mil policías y cinco
mil militares y además regirá el toque
de queda nocturno para algunas
parroquias de localidades como durán no
si son en los puntos críticos
inicialmente en donde la policía tiene
la información en donde existe un mayor
índice delincuencial y posteriormente
conforme las operaciones dando se
modificarán los sectores de acuerdo a
los resultados que se vayan obteniendo
ecuador vive una ola de violencia desde
por lo menos hace un año según cifras
del ministerio de defensa la
delincuencia ha dejado mil 255 muertos
tan sólo en el primer cuatrimestre de
este año eso a todos nos afecta terrible
es terrible a todos nos afecta la
inseguridad ya no podemos estar en
lugares
como con facilidad como uno estaba ante
por ejemplo en caso de que tú vas a un
restaurant ya no se puede ahora compras
para llevar porque ya la inseguridad no
se puede
según el gobierno ecuatoriano el
incremento de la violencia está
directamente ligado al narcotráfico en
la zona vecino de colombia y perú los
mayores productores de cocaína en el
mundo 'ecuador ha servido como puerto de
salida de cargamentos hacia eeuu y
europa
tan solo en lo que va del 2022 ecuador
ha confiscado 75 toneladas de droga
además de los enfrentamientos en las
cárceles una situación que ha azotado al
país en repetidas ocasiones desde
febrero de 2021 han muerto 350 reos en
enfrentamientos por el poder entre
organizaciones del narcotráfico
al menos 23 personas están atrapadas en
las ruinas de un edificio que se
derrumbó en china'
la edificación se desplomó el viernes en
la tarde hora local en la ciudad de
sanya en el centro del país el alcalde
precisó que después del accidente no han
podido contactar a 39 personas pero las
autoridades no tienen claro si ellas
también están debajo de los escombros el
edificio estaba densamente poblado pues
allí había un hotel apartamentos y un
cine real y suyo
no escatimaremos esfuerzos para buscar a
las personas atrapadas bajo el principio
de la vida primero las personas primero
aprovecharemos las 72 horas doradas para
el rescate y haremos todo lo posible
para buscar a las personas atrapadas
hemos enviado más de 700 bomberos
policías armados y socorristas de
emergencia social hemos despachado más
de 120 unidades de vehículos de
extinción de incendios excavadoras
grandes vehículos generadores de energía
y detectores de vida en cooperación con
perros de rescate para llevar a cabo la
operación de rescate en el lugar
y terminamos en nueva york con una obra
de arte que podría hacer historia
hablamos de shot 6 y martín link uno de
los icónicos retratos que integran la
serie el artista andy warhol dedicó a
marilyn monroe en
1964 este cuadro saldrá a subasta a
mediados de mayo en christie's y según
expertos podría superar los 200 millones
de dólares la casa espera que se
convierta en la obra del siglo 20 más
cara jamás vendida en una subasta
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]